hashtag einstein boss wright einstand
hatte recht die gravitationswellen sind
tatsächlich aufgespürt worden
wie sieht ein gewitter aus dem all aus
und das ozonloch über dem nordpol reist
auf das sind drei der fünf themen jetzt
in den krieg zum top news sensationell
das ist nicht nur eines meiner
lieblingswörter sondern am donnerstag
waren sich die physik hat der welt einig
es ist eine sensation die ersten
gravitationswellen wurden gefunden und
damit wurde
nicht mehr und nicht weniger als ein
neues fachgebiet der physik geboren mal
sehen wie es genannt wird ich würde es
gravitationswellen astronomie nennen ab
sofort ist es möglich das weltall
mittels der beobachtung von
gravitationswellen zu untersuchen
jetzt können wir noch viel viel tiefer
ins weltall blicken als es bisher
möglich war
es wird alles verändern zum beispiel
werden wir erforschen können wie sich
supermassereiche schwarze löcher in den
zentren der galaxien gebildet haben
wir werden mehr über den urknall
erfahren vor genau 100 jahren hatte
einstein sie vorhergesagt wählen die vom
großen kosmischen ereignissen ausgehen
und die raumzeit krümmen am dienstag
hatten wir über das gerücht berichtet
dass es erstmals gelungen sein soll
gravitationswellen direkt nachzuweisen
und am donnerstag dann den elften
februar fand gegen 16.30 deutscher
ortszeit die offizielle pressekonferenz
dazu statt und es war ein historischer
moment als dave reid sie der direktor
des gravitationswellen detektor sligo
sagte britischen german way checkten
gravitation wales gravitation ist ja
keine kraft sondern die krümmung der
raumzeit wir hier selbst erleben die
längen kontraktion der raumzeit durch
die gravitation die uns auf die erde
drückt das ist allgemeine
relativitätstheorie die forscher haben
jetzt gravitationswellen gefunden die
vor rund 13 milliarden jahren durch
einen zusammenstoss zweier schwarzer
löcher ausgelöst wurden sie hatten eine
masse von 29 bzw 36 sonnenmassen kurz
vor dem zusammenstoß kreisten sie mit
einer geschwindigkeit von 4.500
umdrehungen pro minute um einander beim
normalen auto ist dass der oberen
drehzahlbereich des motors wenn man
schon ganz ordentlich beschleunigt die
kollision geschah in sekundenbruchteilen
und war dann auch ganz schnell wieder
vorbei
kein wunder schwarze löcher sind ja im
inneren unendlich klein man nennt
singularität viel viel kleiner als ein
stecknadelkopf aufgezeichnet wurden die
daten am 14 september 2015 um 11 uhr 51
deutscher zeit am laser interferometer
gravitation wave of the world toques
kurz lego mit dieser entdeckung wurde
der wohl letzte beweis der von einstein
aufgestellten ralle relativitätstheorie
erbracht mehr informationen dazu sollen
in den nächsten in der nächsten zeit
veröffentlicht werden der link zum video
in dem wir die gravitationswellen
erklären ist in der video beschreibung
dort findet ihr auch das video der
pressekonferenz roboter inspiriert durch
die natur solcher katastrophen helfen
ein neu entwickelter roboter kam selbst
in schwierig zugängliche bereiche
gelangen
die gerade mal ein platz von 37
millimetern bieten um
aufklärungsarbeiten durchzuführen
in der vergangenen woche bei dem
zugunglück nahe bad aibling in
oberbayern hatten die einsatzkräfte mit
erschwerten bedingungen zu kämpfen zwei
züge rasen aus noch immer nicht ganz
klaren gründen frontal ineinander und
durchbohrten sich nahezu gegenseitig bei
der darauffolgenden rettungsaktion
machte den einsatzkräften sowohl das
terra der unfallstelle nahe am wasser
und schwer begehbar als auch die enge in
den zugtrümmern zu schaffen lange zeit
konnte man nicht alle vermissten
unfallopfer finden bei solchen unfällen
oder bei naturkatastrophen wie zum
beispiel erdbeben bei denen schwer
erreichbare und unsichere areale die
bergungsarbeiten erschweren soll der
neue roboter zum einsatz kommen im
fachmagazin proceedings of the national
academy of sciences pnas berichten
experten der university of california in
berkeley von dem von ihnen entwickelten
roboter der in solchen situationen
abhilfe schaffen könnte
mit ihm soll es möglich sein durch enge
wege oder tunnel zu manövrieren
die einen durchgang von gerade mal eben
37 mm österreich ungefähr so groß bieten
sollte das prinzip des prototyps basiert
wie so oft auf der tierwelt genauer
gesagt auf der kakerlake diese kann wenn
sie sich durch enge bereiche quetschen
muss den neuen hund
machen druck ihres eigenen körper
körpers aushalten und durch ritzen
schlüpfen die gerade mal ein platz von
etwas mehr als drei millimetern bieten
habe ich selber mal in russland erlebt
in einem hotel irgendwo in sibirien
ich musste nachts ins bad und machte das
licht an der ganze boden war voller
kakerlaken und in wenigen sekunden waren
sie durch alle möglichen ritzen
verschwunden
die kakerlaken wenn dabei ein trick an
sie nutzen ausschließlich ihre
schienbeine um sich fortzubewegen
herkömmlichen bergungs bzw aufklärungs
roboter tun sich mit solch engen
situationen eben oft schwer zitat aber
wenn es da viele risse schlitze und
kanäle gibt kann man sich vorstellen
einen schwarm dieser roboter hinein zu
werfen um überlebende und sichere
einstiegspunkte für ersthelfer zu suchen
so robert fall einer der wissenschaftler
der neue roboter soll in der lage sein
auf druck von aussen zu reagieren indem
man diesen zu seinem seiten hin weiter
leitet außerdem braucht er nicht seine
kompletten beine um sich fortzubewegen
er nutzt dann auch den schienbeinen
tollen trick das ozonloch über der
arktis wächst wieder eigentlich
schließen sich ja die ozonlöcher über
dem nord und südpol langsam die flur
kohlenwasserstoffe fckw didier
ozonlöcher verursachen sind ja seit dem
jahr 2000 weltweit verboten aber in
diesen wochen herrschen über dem nordpol
extrem ungünstige wetterbedingungen die
zur massiven zerstörung von ozon führen
das alfred-wegener-institut für polar-
und meeresforschung kurz ab warnt vor
einem gigantischen zerstörungspotenzial
der atmosphärischen bedingungen über der
arktis innerhalb von ein paar wochen
soll schon mehr als ein viertel des
ozons über der arktis abgebaut worden
seien so die experten
bei 90 grad - in 20 kilometern höhe
bilden sich dort zurzeit
stratosphärische wolken an denen das
durch den menschen produzierte fckw das
ozon abbauen
durch das fehlende ozon in der
stratosphäre wird weniger uv licht
absorbiert es gelangt also mehr bis zum
boden und kann für die menschen in
diesem bereich das risiko für hautkrebs
die steigern tückisch dabei ist dass es
für die menschen keine veränderung in
der wahrnehmung der intensiveren
bestrahlung gibt es wird zum beispiel
nicht wirklich wärmer dadurch ja und
vorsicht walten lassen sollten vor allem
hellhäutige menschen kleinkinder und
säuglinge auf die fauna entstehen
probleme auch im meer dort könnten algen
negativ betroffen sein die wiederum als
nahrungsquelle für viele tierarten den
vor fünf jahren gab es schon einmal eine
solche warnung das ozonloch produkt
damals die 40 fachen landfläche von
deutschland an alle die sich jetzt
denken ach ja ist ja in der arktis über
den nordpol das ist ja weit von uns weg
die experten weisen darauf hin
sollte sich die meteorologische lage in
der region nicht ändern kann sich das
ozonloch bis europa ausbreiten die aw
weist darauf hin dass man auch hier in
deutschland aufmerksam
die uv vorhersagen des ansässigen
wetterdienstes verfolgen sollte bleiben
wir beim thema atmosphäre und wetter die
erde haben ja schon häufig aus der sicht
der astronauten gesehen
starke gewitter stürme und blitze die
sind allerdings eine seltenheit also
dass die astronauten genau darüber sind
und das filmen können jetzt hat die esa
ein video veröffentlicht welches eine
beeindruckende sicht auf ein gewitter
spektakel zeit gefilmt wurden die
aufnahmen von der international space
station der iss und so sieht's aus
0,9 sekunden weltrekord soll noch
unterboten werden wie lange braucht ihr
um eine lumix club oder auch
zauberwürfel zu lösen egal wie schnell
ihr seid ja es gibt maschinen die sind
einfach schneller
seit neuestem liegt der rekord eines
roboters bei 0,9 sekunden
die menschlichen rekordhalter sind zwar
schnell aber brauchen im vergleich dazu
fast schon eine ewigkeit es gibt
zahlreiche wettbewerbe in denen sich
menschen gegenseitig herausfordern
möglichst schnell den würfel zu lösen
ein 14 jähriger junge ein 14 jähriger
junge der schafft es in unter fünf
sekunden
lukas egger aus quarks will hat nur 49
04 sekunden gebraucht um den rubik's
cube zu lösen also vier sekunden länger
als der rekord der maschinen der roboter
den zwei tüftler jay portland und paul
rose entwickelt haben stellt am 15
februar einen neuen weltrekord auf er
löste den sogenannten standard tube also
einer mit drei mal drei farbflächen in
09 sekunden
ja und so sieht das dann aus
atemberaubenden geschwindigkeit ja und
das ist dann auch in das buch der
rekorde gelandet aber kaum ist der
rekord eingetragen melden sich auch
schon neue anwärter in münchen soll
dieser neue weltrekord schon vorher
unterboten worden zu sein der ingenieur
albert baer wie es seinen roboter szabo
an den drei mal drei würfel in 08 87
sekunden lösen da war erfasst die
maschine den würfel mit zwei webcams und
berechnet den lösungsweg mit einer
software die auf einem laptop läuft bei
seinem versuch am 23 januar aber niemand
vom verlag des guinness buchs der
rekorde anwesend für ein eintrag hat es
also nicht gereicht übrigens lässt sich
jeder standard tube rein rechnerisch in
maximal zwanzig schritten lässt es ist
schon wirklich sensationell dass
einsteins theorie bewiesen wurde
die gravitationswellen was sagt ihr dazu
habt ihr das ganze thema auch so
gespannt wie wir verfolgt oder seid ihr
jetzt darauf gespannt was da noch alles
kommen wird lass es uns in den
kommentaren wissen und vergesst nicht
das kopflose abo des kanals ja und
schaut euch die vielen spannenden videos
hier auf klicks um an wir haben eine
best-of playlist zusammengestellt der
link der ist in der video beschreibung
und hier oben und ami also bis dann
bleibt dran